so you just beat king's fall and you're
one of the lucky few to see a beautiful
shiny exotic drop from the last chest
it's touch of malice and it kicks major
ass now to unlock the full potential of
the excellent exotic scout rifle all you
need is the catalyst easy right in this
video we're going to break down how to
get the catalyst i'll explain verbally
how it all works and what you need to
know and then we'll play out the
gameplay at the end of each section
timestamps will be in the video in case
you're looking for something particular
let's get to it
before you start you will ideally want
to run this with a group that also has
touch of malice however it's not
mandatory when you load into king's fall
take some time to check out the court of
oryx without starting the encounter the
idea is simple you want to look for a
plate with touch of malice equipped
stepping onto the plate will cause four
relics to appear scattered across the
arena which will require one runner each
as soon as the relics are picked up by
four runners three shriekers will appear
between your team and a dunk spot
similar to the statues you would
normally dunk in the first encounter of
the raid you will have a time limit but
it's pretty generous and if you fail you
can always retry without needing to
restart the encounter or to wipe
the three areas you will need to do this
are the starting room before the
encounter or the portal golgarat's maze
where the second secret chest is located
and lastly during the final jumping
puzzle with the wall pistons oh
[ __ ]
so let's start with the first plate the
plate you're looking for to activate is
going to be on the left pathway anyone
who has done the first encounter
normally and usually runs down the left
path they can quickly find the plate but
i'll also show you the pathway in the
gameplay shown as mentioned earlier you
want to activate the plate and then
spend some time splitting up your team
to scour the place to search for four
relics that pop up it is worth
mentioning they do always spawn in the
same spots there's just more than 4
spawn points so if you find a relic but
are unsuccessful in getting the whole
team to dunk at the same time it may or
may not respawn the same spot as before
the setup is simple and will occur again
in the later parts of the raid the two
people who are not running relics have
to shoot the shriekers down because they
can be troublesome your final
destination is looking for an extra
statue behind the portal and it'll have
an indicator on it ready for your team
to dunk all four relics for the first
area a couple of places to keep an eye
out for that ended up tricking my team
is under the starting point bridge and
behind the pillar in the starting middle
area i found that just taking my usual
path down the left and the right sides
as if i were running through that first
encounter of the raid that tended to be
the best option and after checking every
nook and cranny i was able to find all
the relics so take a look
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's yeah one's up here i'll stay this
one
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the second time you will have to run
through this is in golgi's maze i
strongly encourage you to pull up one of
the helpful maps from reddit or discord
servers i'll pop in the one that my team
uses all the time here
have your team split up and go towards
each plate as if you were to activate
the secret chest there is a very strong
chance the relics you are looking for
are along the pathways or adjacent to
the plates however you won't be able to
see the relics until you activate the
catalyst specific plate which is to the
side of the secret chest so go to your
regular plates open up the chest and
then look into a nearby wall to see a
touch of malice plate once someone
activates it and causes the relics to
appear take your time return to your
earlier plates to see where the four
relics spawned your endpoint will be in
one of the circular pits near the end of
the maze usually those hole in the
grounds will cause you to die but if you
look at this one you'll see a relic
statue on the inside have your team pop
in there with the relics and dunk
yeah relics of courtney yep awesome was
it the same was it by your plates it's
right in front of point three oh hell
yeah okay lovely
i have a relic it's not in front of any
plate okay
very good
is it over a hole by chance
no but it's also up it's like on mine's
over a hole
okay
yours good to know good to know
uh let me run to epic
so i'm trying to play you don't have to
jump over the hole to get it i can
literally stand on the edge and grab it
nice okay good to know i can't not say
mine is a holy relic gosh dang it i
couldn't i couldn't resist
all right uh so epic yours is in front
of one essentially oh i found one nice
okay that's gonna be all four so just
hang tight i'll run to you
in a second
let me make my way to that
now you're said yours was up in the air
right
yeah i'm like on i'm right now oh nice
hell yeah
okay very good
so it's it's kind of by play number what
is that two okay but it's not on it's on
the pillar very good
spoon where are you at
[Music]
oh really okay
hey
on the other side of this wall
oh nice awesome okay
countdown three two one go
very nice
i see no shriekers
i heard him i thought
oh really yet
yet i heard like the silent little
scream but i think that that was just
like spooky ambiance more than anything
else
the like wilhelm screen or whatever
meeting you here
oh my god
we're all the same thing
i hate when i show up to a party without
the same thing as everybody else this is
the worst potluck ever
i was supposed to bring the dark energy
i thought i was bringing the relic i
called it all right now we've reached
the final piece of the puzzle and
probably the hardest first go about your
platforming and grab the third secret
chest if you so wish then continue
through the jumping puzzle and lock the
floating pathways at the end you'll see
a final touch of malice plate when you
step on it you're gonna see the relics
appear in some pretty silly spots but at
least they're really easy to spot if you
have a teammate stand on the opposite
side of the area the three shriekers
that spawn here are very scattered so
you will want one guardian on shrieker
duty near the touch of malice plate one
kind of floating around the middle and
the person that runs the relic closest
to the end point taking out a shrieker
in that area and then grabbing their
relic although to be honest you could go
about this any way that you wish
depending on what's easier for your team
only thing to really keep an eye out for
behind the shriekers is the pathway to
the final relic which will appear once
you activate the plate it's pretty windy
and really far up in the opposite corner
of where you would normally exit the
jumping puzzle so definitely keep an eye
out for pistons there's one in
particular that can mess you up right at
the end of the pathway
three two one go
okay one shrieker's down
uh spoons disposable it's okay
yeah
courtney help courtney help courtney how
are you drawing
you're not looking at me
what's happening
yeah there we go how did that shrieker
just respawn all of its health dude that
was dumb all right that one's dead all
right thank you did you see that yeah no
no i saw that i saw it i was shooting at
it i was shooting at it too
buggy as hell
i believe i believe
if we don't 360 off the last platform
here you know
we wipe for damage
we wipe for relic
argo you might wanna 15 seconds
you might want to hustle a little bit
oh my god come on argo
go for it pop it
nice or expected you to his court once
everyone dunks a hilarious mini area
opens up that i believe was an easter
egg from destiny 1. you'll see a bunch
of launch pads just hop into one and
grab a floating relic and start slamming
them down like you're at an nba dunk
contest you'll have a generous amount of
time to dunk as many relics as your team
possibly can and eventually the catalyst
should appear for those curious the
catalyst adds on rapid hit as an extra
perk which is huge since it increases
reload speed and stability with up to a
5 time stack fun pro tip if you decide
to test it out on oryx pop the charge
with blight ability when you reach a
times 10 stack and you'll get a damage
boost it's pretty simple once you get
the hang of it if you want more guides
let me know in the comments and let me
know what other destiny content you
would like to see from gamespot
our very own phil hornshaw writes
destiny guides features and op-eds all
the time so be sure to check out his
iron banter column lore drops and as
well as some of the dev interviews with
some of destiny senior developers and
game directors as for me i'll be diving
back into some king's fall challenges
next week and seeing if i could solo
some of these dungeons with the new arc
3.0 builds until next time
[Music]
you